the movie opens up with a short
introduction about dogs being used
during the times of the first world war
it is also mentioned that more than 3
000 dogs served in the u.s military
forces during their war time in iraq and
afghanistan following this a
well-trained army dog max is seen
leading a group of u.s soldiers to a
village in afghanistan while the
villagers are protesting against the
arrival of the soldiers max and his
handler kyle enter a house max
continuously smells over a carpet and
discovers the hidden compartment of guns
and other deadly ammunition it is then
proven that the villagers are selling
illegal ammunition to the terrorists
after a tough day at work kyle returns
to his base and talks to his parents
back home mother pamela and father ray
rey is also a retired u.s military
officer the parents seem to love max and
they treat him like a member of their
family however kyle's brother justin
does not seem to be fond of dogs he also
does not like his father being strict
and trying to keep him under control
justin mostly plays video games hey
what's wrong with being a gamer and even
pirates them to sell in his friend's
circle okay that's messed up in the next
scene kyle is called by his superior to
his office there the superior tells kyle
that the guns they collected from the
village the other day are less in number
and doubts that someone from their group
is stealing them kyle then confronts his
group and gets to know that his best
friend tyler is the one who is doing all
of this however since he does not want
to ruin their friendship he decides to
give tyler a chance the next day when
kyle and his group are on their next
mission max leads them to a place and
stops in the middle as if he has sensed
something in the meantime kyle confronts
tyler that he knows about his illegal
business of smuggling weapons however
instead of apologizing tyler asks kyle
to remain quiet and focus on the mission
he also orders max to keep going and
because of this max runs into a trap set
by the terrorists sadly a number of
explosions occur around max and seeing
this kyle runs to save his beloved dog
he asks tyler to provide him with cover
but tyler leaves him alone and hides in
a safe place as a result kyle is killed
in the shootout in the following scene
the military officers visit kyle's house
to inform his family about his death
when the family is supplied with the
news the parents along with justin are
devastated later the family gathers in a
church to perform the last rites for
kyle and max is also brought there he
seems very sad to have lost his master
and silently sits beside his coffin
after the ceremony when the officers try
to take max away to their military base
he does not comply with them and
retaliates however the dog recognizes
justin and approaches him believing that
he will take care of him like kyle did
sadly justin accompanies the police
officers and helps them put max inside a
police van to take him to a dog shelter
the next day as justin is playing video
games he starts reminiscing about his
late brother sad he visits kyle's room
and goes through his pictures and
belongings at the same time rey also
arrives there and tries to console him
surprisingly justin erupts and blames
his father for kyle's death while the
father-son duo is arguing over the
matter pamela arrives there and informs
them that max is going to be put down by
the military officers wasting no time
the family goes straight to the dog
shelter to see max there they meet with
one of the dog's caretakers who informs
them about max being violent and out of
control he also states that max has been
traumatized because of kyle's death and
has started to react violently to any
loud noise or person around him to their
surprise when justin enters the room max
becomes silent and sits on the floor max
seems to follow justin's orders as he
apparently senses kyle-like features in
him after seeing max behaving friendly
with justin the family decides to adopt
max moments later justin and the family
return home but ray mentions that they
cannot take max inside as he is too
dangerous hence they are compelled to
tie him up outside the house later at
night max keeps on barking and howling
disturbing the family as well as the
neighbors rey yells at justin and asks
him to silence max reluctantly justin
wakes up from his bed and goes outside
to calm the dog as expected max becomes
silent after seeing him but does not
allow him to leave afterward with this
justin is compelled to accompany him
just like kylie used to in the military
camp after justin falls asleep max comes
near him and guards him like a loyal dog
the next morning justin wakes up and
goes to meet his friend chewie there he
also comes across chewie's cousin carmen
who seems to be fond of dogs when justin
mentions that he is having trouble with
his dog carmen offers to help him take
control of him and also train him in the
following scene justin can be seen
getting ready for carmen's arrival
putting on his best clothes to impress
her moments later carmen and chewie
arrive there carmen teaches some tricks
to justin about how to go near a dog and
make him obey orders after some hours of
training justin is finally able to make
max walk alongside him just then pamela
approaches chewie and carmen and invites
them to stay for dinner during the
dinner pamela talks about kyle and
starts crying making everyone feel
awkward outside max starts barking
aggressively and soon the doorbell rings
when justin opens the door he finds
tyler on the other side the parents are
happy to see their son's best friend and
inquire about the reason for his sudden
return from the service tyler tells them
that he was injured in one of the
battles and has returned home for
recovery hearing this rey invites tyler
to the july parade later when the family
takes tyler to see max surprisingly the
dog becomes aggressive and starts
barking max even breaks his chain and
tries to attack tyler get him boy he's
an [ __ ] fortunately justin and carmen
stop him in the neck of time here we get
to know that max hasn't forgotten about
the incident and has an eye for
vengeance the next day justin takes max
to a bicycle park where he rides with
his friends and max follows him around
later when justin returns home he is
surprised to find a cage in the front
yard on asking pamela he gets to know
that rey has made it for max so that he
won't be able to attack other people
like he did with tyler the previous day
later that day after locking max in the
cage the whole family goes to the july
parade while others stay to enjoy the
fireworks justin realizes that max is
alone and returns he arrives home to
find max terrified because of the
fireworks justin tries to take max out
of the cage but the poor dog doesn't
move an inch as a result justin enters
the cage and sits alongside max to calm
him down the next day tyler meets with
ray and requests to let him work in his
warehouse during his vacation ray also
becomes happy and readily accepts his
request later while conversing rey asks
tyler about how his son died expectedly
tyler lies mentioning that max was the
reason for kyle's death as the dog
disobeyed his orders and ran into the
danger zone hearing this ray becomes
enraged and rushes home with the
intention to release his anger on max he
takes out a gun and points it at max but
fortunately justin arrives there and
stops him in the next scene justin
visits the military dog shelter and
talks with one of kyle's friends
sergeant reyes reyes tells him that max
is the best dog that has ever been
trained in their facility and also
assures him that max could have never
hurt kyle furthermore he informs him
that tyler is actually suspended from
his job and also provides him with a dvd
containing videos of kyle training max
for the first time following this justin
visits chewie's house and asks carmen to
watch the dvd with him when he sees max
being friendly and obedient to kyle in
the video he dismisses his doubt about
max turning up on kyle in the meantime
chewie's other cousin emilio who is
associated with a cartel meets justin
and forces him to provide him with a
game that has been released recently
while they are talking emilia receives a
call from tyler and this makes justin
suspicious hence as soon as emilio
leaves he along with max start following
him after some time justin arrives at a
place in the middle of the woods where
he can clearly see tyler meeting with
emilio soon a group of italian gangsters
also arrive who are eager to buy weapons
from tyler here justin gets to know that
tyler is actually smuggling weapons from
afghanistan and selling them in the
states right then the gangster's dogs
hear max barking and start running
towards him despite being outnumbered he
defeats the two dogs and escapes with
justin while running away justin bumps
over a rock and his bicycle goes flying
into a ditch as a result he is forced to
run on foot through the dense forest
luckily they managed to reach the
highway where a decent lady offers them
a lift and drops them off at home when
justin walks inside his house he is
surprised to see tyler and his illegal
business partner deputy stack talking
with his parents it turns out that tyler
discovered justin's bicycle in the woods
and deduced that he saw them dealing the
weapons meanwhile stack pretends to have
a wound on his hand and also claims that
it is because of max he then tells the
parents that they should take away max
as he is a danger to everyone when
justin protests tyler asks to talk to
him privately and threatens him to keep
his mouth shut afraid for the safety of
his family he agrees to let max go
moments later the dog shelter employees
arrive there and take max away in the
next scene tyler returns to work and
there ray confronts him for using one of
their storage units without any
paperwork in reality tyler is using it
to store guns but he lies that it is
being used by his friend on the other
hand max is brought to the dog shelter
but is very difficult to control in no
time he runs away from the place after
attacking the security guards later at
night ray walks up to justin and tries
to strike up a conversation but the
latter remains silent rey immediately
deduces that his son is hiding something
and urges him to speak but as justin is
scared he does not reveal anything later
rey visits his storage unit and catches
tyler and stack loading guns in a truck
he confronts them but is held hostage by
emilio meanwhile pamela gets a strange
voicemail from rey informing her that he
will be spending the night in one of
their hunting houses the voicemail is
strange because pamela does not recall
owning a hunting house right then max
arrives outside the house and seeing him
justin and pamela become happy justin
then takes max and goes straight to
chewie's house there he tells chewie and
carmen about his father's absence and
the group goes out to search for him
they arrive at the storage units and
find a broken lock max smells the lock
and guides them towards rey after
roaming around the whole night justin
and his group finally arrive at a
secluded place in the woods they spot
tyler and his group dealing in weapons
with rey inside their car held hostage
sensing the danger carmen returns to
inform the police while justin and
chewie keep an eye on tyler and his
associates unfortunately the dogs
brought by tyler's associates realize
the group's presence and start running
towards them surprisingly even this time
max defeats the two dogs because of this
tyler and emilio rush towards the woods
to find justin when rey notices that
stack is alone and has no one around he
manages to attack him and free himself
soon max and justin arrive there and the
father-son duo have an emotional reunion
however the danger has not been averted
yet so they decide to make a plan both
of them walk on different routes to
confuse tyler meanwhile stack gets
inside his car and starts searching for
the father-son duo when he spots rey and
tries to run him over race shoots the
car causing it to disbalance and explode
under a bridge elsewhere justin caught
by tyler who holds him at gunpoint tyler
expresses his frustration for not being
able to close the deal because of justin
and prepares to shoot him right then max
attacks tyler from behind causing both
of them to fall from the bridge and into
the river below carmen also arrives with
the officers and all the bad guys are
arrested in the last scene justin and
max can be seen in front of kyle's grave
where justin is expressing his feelings
for him justin thanks kyle for leaving a
dog like max and salutes him for the
first time later when he returns home he
finds carmen and chewie inside his house
with pamela preparing for dinner justin
is surprised when he does not find max's
cage outside the house he asks rey about
it to which he replies that they won't
be needing it anymore as max will be
living with them as a family member to
all the dog owners out there please take
the best care you can of your pop my dog
ran away during a thunderstorm and i
never saw him again they really are
family members and they deserve the best
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching